every time you try to learn something
you're going to make a mistake when you
make a mistake you don't get to beat
yourself to death with a club it's a bad
strategy
you know no one's perfect
so
people make their mistakes as they
stumble uphill
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are and certainly
many young men are in that category what
do you do with messages of error
and that's a tricky issue okay so here's
a solution to that
here's what not to do I am a bad person
I might as well just go jump off the
bridge it's like no that's not good
every time you try to learn something
you're going to make a mistake because
what do you know so you're going to make
mistakes and if the rule is every time
you make a mistake you're gonna go jump
off the bridge then that's not a useful
problem-solving strategy I don't care
what you're gonna do but go out there
and make something of yourself for God's
sake be an honest person and work and
get to the top of whatever it is that
you want to get to the top of you know
and and and and stand up for yourself
like a respectable human being and be a
bit of a light on the world instead of a
blight you know and you can tell young
people that and they haven't been told
that by anyone now the tragic sense of
being is there with people all the time
and and it's also the case that my in my
experience like I rarely meet someone
who says hey you know
I'm doing everything I possibly can I'm
a hell of a guy and I can't see how I
could possibly improve you know but most
people don't feel that way they feel
like they could do a hell of a lot
better than they are and they're quite
acutely aware of their faults and they
don't feel that they're what they should
be when people become self-conscious if
at least that's how it looks to me they
get thrown out of paradise and then
they're in history and history is a
place where there's pain in childbirth
and where you're dominated by your mate
and where you have to toil like mad like
no other animal because you're aware of
the future you have to work and
sacrifice the joys of the present for
the future constantly and you know
you're going to die and you have all
that weight on you and to me again
that's just how can anything be more
true than that that's just as far as I
can tell that's just how it is for
unless you're naive Beyond Comprehension
there's something about your life that
that that is echoed in in that
representation and people
make mistakes that they know they
shouldn't make and make anyways they sin
right and that's to miss the mark right
because that's an archery term to sin
and that means maybe they don't even
specify the damn Target which is really
you're not going to hit it unless you
specified or having specified it they
just say
oh to hell with it it's not that
important it's like you got to be
careful when you say something like to
hell with it it's not that important
because one of the things that might
happen to you if you say to hell with it
it's not that important is that you
might actually end up in hell for a
pretty prolonged period of time or maybe
for the REM remainder of your miserable
existence because it's certainly the
case that people do exist there and I've
seen them exist there and once you're
there it's no simple matter to get the
hell out and so it might matter that the
things that matter get addressed
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now if people got
their act together and really aimed at
it because you know my my experience is
with people that we're probably running
at about 51 percent of our capacity and
so if your life isn't everything it
could be you could ask yourself well
what would happen if you just stopped
wasting the opportunities that are in
front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
no one can tell you how it will work for
you it's the thing that your destiny is
to discover that
and you have to make you have to make
the decisions to begin with It's like
because you can't do this without
commitment you have to commit to it
first that's the act of faith that that
Kierkegaard was so insistent upon you
have to say I'm going to act as if being
is good I'm going to act as if truth is
the pathway to Enlightenment I'm going
to act as if I should pursue the deepest
meaning possible in my life
no matter what you do you're all in so I
think you might as well play the most
magnificent game you can
while you're waiting because do you have
anything better to do really
Why not pick the best thing possible
that you could do
why not do that the answer is right in
front of you and if you can't see it
it's not because life has no meaning
it's because you're blind
you're blind to your own weaknesses but
you're also blind to your own strengths
and so then I think well if you've got
your act together it'd be better for you
and instantly it would be better for
your family assuming they wanted you to
get your act together and not everyone
does but if you stopped wasting time and
if you stop lying and if you oriented
yourself to to the highest possible good
that you could conceive of and you
committed to that how much good could
you do
well I would say why don't you find out
so that's what I think you should do
you should find out there's nothing in
it but good
it's really something to see
constantly
how many people
are dying for a lack of an encouraging
word
and how easy it is to provide that if
you're careful
you know give credit where credit is due
and to say
you're a net force for good if you want
to be
this is something I learned from
studying the behaviorists is like watch
the people around you like a hawk
whenever they do something that you
think is good you tell them
that's wisdom man you'll get so far with
that you cannot bloody well believe it
because most people you know they're
afraid
any number of things but one of the
things they're really afraid of is that
now and then they'll creep out of their
cynical shell and try to do something
good you know it's like they're it's
like they're popping out this thing
that's unbelievably vulnerable
try to do something good and creep right
back into their Persona and they'll look
around see if anyone noticed and
sometimes they'll get punished for it
and then well then they won't do it
again so don't do that but then now and
then you think hey I saw you do this it
was actually that was actually pretty
good
wow someone noticed it looks like wow
and then they'll think yeah I could
maybe I could do that again